I sort of particularly resent the re
racialization of society because I think
it is making everybody notice things
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Frances Foster i'm konstantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you're
bored with people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about a trigonometry we don't pretend to
be the experts we ask the experts
our fantastic guests this week needs
very little introduction he's a
journalist and an author of an upcoming
book in fact it out already the madness
of crowds Douglas Murray welcome back to
trigonometry it's a great pleasure to be
back with you well here we are we spoke
to you only a few months ago and it
seems things have evolved not only with
you but with the world in general sure
had one of the things we wanted to talk
to you about the book which is
absolutely fantastic I recommend it to
anyone who's watching or listening to
this is some of the bigger issues behind
what you're talking about because you
break it down you go into the gay the
women the trans the race stuff but the
bigger issue I think behind what you
talk about in the book is we now we
almost it's not that we don't we live in
a post truth society we almost live in
an anti truth society now in a society
in which saying things which are
patently true scientifically verifiable
has become dangerous yes yes that's
right that's it so that's really why I
wanted to write the madness of crowds
because I'm aware just as you're aware
that there's an awful lot of things that
we were expected to believe and
certainly a lot of things were expected
to say which basically people don't
believe and I think that's a very
unhealthy thing for society to do I
think it's an unhealthy state for any
group of people to be in but that's
that's good terrain for writer like it
is for a comedian because you know i
I've I've developed this realization
while writing the book but almost
everybody is vulnerable when I started
writing the madness of crowds and
looking into all of the you know
intersectional ISM and all of this mad
I you know I knew how I knew it had
spilled out a long time ago from the
American Academy from Berkeley in these
places I knew it had gone a long way
into the popular culture I knew all of
that one of the things I was surprised
that was the extent to which it is just
washed across the corporate world you
know washed across you know places which
you would think you know you might not
like me would have thought would have
been grownups you know my god no they've
all imbibed the whole thing and what I
realized was then that almost nobody
could speak the truth
nobody even think aloud apart from as it
turns out the small number of people who
don't have a wobbly hierarchy above us
because basically in this society at the
moment if you have a hierarchy above you
it is very likely to be wobbly it is
likely to if a new demand is made of
everyone today to do it by tomorrow and
if you stand up against that you're
toast
so this weird thing is the most where
people who don't have a wobbly hierarchy
are the only people able to say what
everybody knows and that turns out
mainly to consist of writers and
comedians that is that's a perilous
thing might be really screwed if that's
who we've got to rely on but I think it
is I think it is and I think that people
like you people like me have a strange
disproportionate burden and indeed duty
to keep speaking and I'm just thrilled
by the fact that that is happening you
know in just in recent weeks we've seen
Dave Chappelle break out on some of
these things and we've seen a few other
people do it and you know fine if if the
adults in the room all go mad and they
tell the young people to go mad as well
then maybe it's just a few comedians and
writers who can say not doing it do you
think that this in a way is a sort of
divide and conquer and
especially with identity politics if
it's white against black straight
against gay in the gay communities
becomes even more fracture but the whole
transition yeah yeah yeah the the CVL
the elves don't get on with the geez and
the LS and G's very suspicious of the
bees and all of them kind of bow the t's
so you nail DBT thing doesn't doesn't
doesn't work as a group I think there is
there are several things going on and I
try it in the matters of crowded I try
to explain what I think the main bits
are there is one part of this that has
is a is a very straightforward post
Marxist agenda which is the working
class let them down the working class
never did come up with the revolution
properly and they failed to totally
transform human society and indeed made
the biggest mess in history everywhere
they tried it so working class let the
Marxists down but they were very again
until I was reading all the texts on
this I was surprised I was our surprise
I discovered them how Frank some of the
Marxists were in the eighties even
straight forward they stated in terms
and I quote them working-class let us
down we need a new revolutionary set of
groups and these will include women
sexual minorities racial minorities and
we need to make them the vanguard of the
revolution
so that's one group that's what one
group of things that are going on
another group I would say are people for
whom this is just brood politics you
know the people who say you're not gay
if you're gay and not a revolutionary
Marxist the people who say people aren't
black anymore III give him the race
chapter I said of what I just regard as
being unbelievably hilarious examples of
this I think my favorite of which is
near the assumption that black is about
being political which is such a racist
idea and all these sort of woke figures
do it but my fav my favorite one by the
way Atari is is
the London School of Economics has a
review of a book by Thomas sul the
amazing American academic and thinker
Thomas solo of course it is is black and
and quite conservative and there was
this review of a book of his I think of
society in his discontents was published
on the LSE book review site a few years
ago and it has what I think of as being
the best correction of any correction
ever published because this review takes
a just run straight at Thomas soul it's
all bigotry it's all disguise big if
it's all wolf what you know it's all
it's all dog with it's all dog whistles
and and and all this but but at the
bottle is full frontal attack hunt on
the soul is a little errata thing at the
bottom he says an earlier version of
this article included the phrase that's
easy for rich white man to say the
reviewer hadn't even looked at the dust
jacket it turned out but but I say this
because there is this amazing amazing
thing where people get told they're not
black if they have the wrong part it's
just like some people tell them they're
not gave the wrong politics and some
people are told they're not women if
they have the wrong policies because
because of course you would expect 50%
of the species to have entirely
longstead views and this is this is
brute politics this is nothing more this
is this is using identity groups as a
battering ram for political gain and I
think it's it's disgusting but we need
to call it out but the other group so
the final group on that is and this is
the one I know where I want to most
address is young people who believe this
for perfectly good reasons as in you
know you're starting off in life you are
told that you live in an incredibly
oppressive society you don't have as we
don't have one we're going up much sense
of historical comparison to make you do
tend to believe the things you're told
by authority figures and if your
authority figures tell you that you live
in an unbelievably patriarchal ray
this sexist society and so on then
you'll throw imbibe that and then you're
told you know to find meaning in your
life you should fight against that and
take on those forces and you should
triumf over them and you should you
should you should destroy them I can see
the attraction in it and one of the
necessary tasks I think will be to try
to de-escalate those people and we help
them reorient their lives on to lives of
greater meaning do you think part of
this is the fact that we do live in a
society where you know people talk about
intergenerational unfairness we live in
a society post the crash for example
where it's very difficult and I've been
saying this for a while now to expect
young people to be capitalists when they
don't have a chance of having the one
form of capital that historically
ordinary people have ever had which is
to own their own home if we live in that
society I think it's going to be quite
difficult to deescalate and convince
young people now that they they don't
live in in that kind of society because
if they look around they feel like well
maybe life isn't fair in this yeah yeah
the I say this in the introduction that
it's not clear why people who don't have
any ability to accumulate capital will
love capitalism it's not clear why em
why it is clear to me however why if you
don't think you for instance ever have a
chance of owning a flat and apartment
you might find an ideology which claims
that it can solve every inequity on
earth it has an appeal you know it's
obvious what the appeal could be and I
don't particularly blame people for
falling into that at least for a period
I think they should fall out of it if
they can but but yes I mean that the the
assumption you know historically I think
we've all understood haven't we that if
the economics goes bad other things go
bad in quite fast order one of the
things I think I try to show in the
madness of crowds is the economics went
bad we sort of pretended that that
wouldn't have consequences but I think
that among the consequences of it is
that
bad ideas that were waiting in the wings
flooded into the system because our
immune system was low and we are we are
suffering for that you know all this
stuff when I started reading a few years
ago there's sort of the basics of what
we now call intersections and the
academic basis for it I assumed I'd find
you know impenetrable badly-written not
that well argued but serious texts no I
mean one of the most prominent
foundational texts though intersection
ism is is by peggy mcintosh it's called
unpacking the knapsack and I urge people
to have a look at it because it's a few
pages long and it is just a list of
assertions it's not even an argument
it's a list of assertions and that's
where I idea of white privilege comes
from just from that little lesson yeah I
thought at least they'll have really
tried to work this out and before they
tried to impose it on every society on
earth I'd have thought they'd have
they'd have done a bit of work there
isn't that much work to it and and but
and as I say that was that was sort of
this stuff was lying there in the wings
but it's only in the last ten years that
it comes whooshing through and in the
last five years and you can you can show
this an online activity my other things
in the last five years it becomes
absolutely you know the the weaponized
tool of politics and and that did
surprise me but as I say it happened for
what I think is a clear historical
reason which is that we were vulnerable
for such a movement why this I mean we
couldn't be the first human beings in
history who had no explanation for what
we should be doing on earth I mean
you can get by with that it is my view
you can get by with not having an
explanation for what to do so long as
the economics are going quite well as
long as basically you're always getting
rich and you you know every generations
rich isn't their parents and there were
various ways around that we sort of
coped with for a while or put out there
for a while such as while it's true it
might be harder for this generation to
get on the housing ladder than their
parents but they've got iPhones some of
that might do it some of it clearly
doesn't but but this thing about meaning
about what are we actually doing you can
have the distractions you can enjoy
yourself God knows I'm not being a
Puritan about this but that's probably
not enough and so anything that has an
appeal to meaning has a good chance in
such a mirror and here is here is
probably the it's not a great idea
system the intersectional social justice
warrior identity politics system it's
not a great idea system but it's
probably the the most ambitious and
plausible one to come up since the end
of the Cold War
they haven't meanness or another new ish
idea you may be green ideology and you
know green politicking and green meaning
but other than that there's not much
else as washing around so not surprised
and you think it's become so successful
because it appeals primarily to the
emotions to the heart by were in in
certain instances we all feel cheated
looked over we all feel frustrated and
if somebody comes along and offers you a
very very simple solution to that it's
because you're black gay whatever it is
you see see to go on almost yeah I mean
I'm I'm very interested in the way in
which this ear I think we talked about
as a little when we last met this era
aspires to go down I mean it's the
fascinating things that we talked about
I think last time in terms of you know
the wanting to be insulted one thing to
be like oh my god have you seen what I
get on Twitter
lie down and that there's no particular
advantage the heroism whereas there is
of being a victim you know and and and
this this sort of downward aspiration is
is it's a number of things but one is
obviously one is obviously that it's
it's a it's a it's a flag sent up to ask
the mob to pass over you you know I
think as some survival mechanism in some
of this which is really fascinating I
talk about this in the book in terms of
the cuttlefish which fascinated me was
having its discussion with those one day
the chapter on women is to some extent
the one that probably all may get me in
the most trouble because I mean the
trans one is already getting me into
some trouble for saying you know really
just I think an honest and and humane
way I'm no I'm not trying to just soap
you or anything out well I should be go
and that's what one of the things that
struck me about the chapter on trans
anyone who who who would read your
critics Douglas Murray is this
right-wing bigger blah blah blah I think
would be quite shocked by how
compassionate your and thorough and
careful you are to delineate a lot of
these things and to show that you were
actually trying to understand where
people may choose to transition that's
right rather than just dismissing this
whole thing all these people what mental
illness whatever yeah no I've spoken to
a lot of people and I've read a lot of
people's testimonies and accounts and I
do try very very carefully I want to say
salami slicing was not quite the right
metaphor but but but I want to just
carefully trace what is plausible and
what is dementing in the demand because
at the moment they're all put in the
same thing so it's somebody born with
genital abnormalities is put in the same
category as you know say the big bit in
man with a penis is a woman or or you're
bigger and that's not fair it's not a
fair to the fair to the first group just
to begin with so yeah I do try
so really hard to in all these cases to
look at what the plausible bit is and
then say what are we leaning too heavily
on and what are we pretending we know
about which we really don't know about
and I think I think there's two there's
twin problems which I try to identify in
this book and to answer which is we have
in our society the problem of pretending
we know about things that we don't
really know about and I put the trans
one in there we pretend to be really
sure now and we shouldn't be shocked
because we're not but the flip side of
that is we also pretend not to know
about things we all knew till yesterday
and I mean Mina maybe maybe we're not
allowed to say this but because this is
three men talking and obviously men
shouldn't talk about women because what
interest could men have in women but you
know a lot of the stuff about relations
between sexes it's complicated but it's
not that complicated we all there are
load of things we pretend we don't know
which we knew till yesterday and we
could do with remembering and I as I say
I think some of this might get me into
most trouble because there's a lot of
women who have quite enjoyed the
overcorrection
and quite enjoyed not looking at some of
the let's say more more difficult things
that we actually need to think about
what's what's the Forgotten knowledge
you know any habit to get back to my car
I was gonna get demonetized
[Music]
but seriously though on the men and
women thing I it's one of the it's been
thus one of the staples of comedy
throughout after decades the differences
between men and women they're like a man
who's a bit of a klutz yeah I'm at the
man who can't the the pathetic silly man
who can't do the stuff and the woman has
to show it yeah the exciting thing about
that in comedy is that is once hack now
that's groundbreaking yeah no go on
stakes a difference between men and
women there's a tension in the air can
you say it can you not I mean we don't
know where we stand anymore it's very
exciting but it is very interesting
there's no particularly for both of us
because we live with women it's like you
go home and you suddenly need even if
you bought into all this crap you go
home when you go nun up we're not
exactly the same we think about things
very differently we have different
attitudes and if you have a son and a
daughter you'll notice it yeah but but
but yes I mean what are we not talking
about there no that's just oh well a few
juicy details huh how about this one we
everything in everything in the ideology
we've been imbibing relies on the idea
there's only one foot well firstly that
power is the single most important thing
in the world and it's a means through
which you understand everything and I
think we got this through a version of
Foucault and other things and really
ugly reading of the past and indeed of
the present power is the one thing that
matters the one means by which we
understand the world I think this is
wrong because I've always had you before
I think that for most people if you said
some what's the thing in their life that
matters most they'd probably say love
mmm some version of that my husband well
my wife my children my family my my God
my whatever you know all sorts of thing
but there are very few people unless
you've got an absolute maniac in front
of you you would say well then that
would be the thing that would tell you
they're a [ __ ] Romania absolutely so
it's a it's it's a dementing thing for a
society to take a maniacal view and
assume it's true and so that so that's
the first thing but the one foot but so
the first thing is we we have this idea
that power is the thing but then
secondly we've fallen into this
that there's only one real type of power
in the world and it is white
heterosexual male power mainly old now
of course we all know some of the ugly
things of that leads to such as the
presumption that you know the unemployed
steel worker in the north of England is
just unbelievably privileged you know
and can be lectured to by a millionaire
so long as they are black or a female or
gay and the power structure is still
that way around but one of the things I
address in the chapter on women which is
as I say I mean it's is this I is when
all men get nervous but what if there
are other types of power hmm what if
what if there are types of power the
only women wield what if they actually
have more power and okay not in every
situation in some situations and now one
way I might refine this is to say and
again just got to hope people recognize
this because if they don't you're toast
but is there any form of male power any
form of legal male power equivalent to
the power that a very attractive woman
in her late teens early 20s has when
speaking to a man two to three times her
age I'm uncomfortable yeah we all will
know it was all seen it mm-hmm okay
I'd like to see the the epitome of white
male power wealth with two people in
front of him one an incredibly beautiful
attractive woman who knows how to use it
and the other one a man with not much in
the looks department
do we actually think that the powerful
male looks at these two people in
exactly the same way do we think that no
woman knows what she might have in that
scenario and none of them have ever
weaponized it or would seek to weaponize
or use it or in any way I don't think so
I think we all know that there are
things you can do I don't think by the
way there's almost any male equivalent
of that a very successful woman in her
50s is much less likely if meeting a hot
guy in his early 20s let alone a team to
risk everything in her life and career
in order to have a few minutes of fun is
almost impossible and it doesn't have to
be that sinister either I mean my wife
and I for example whenever we need to go
and talk to someone to get a favor or
whatever she'll always go and do it cuz
yeah yeah absolutely would you mind you
know being home because I think it'll
come out better yeah and it's just a
fact and it's not necessarily a sinister
form of Polaris just how human beings
relate to each other based on our sexual
evolution that's what that's the human
beings that we are you gonna are we
gonna pretend that's not the case right
but it's amazing that this narrative has
been created and we all know that parts
of this narrative are a lot of it are
false and yet we talk about this fear
constantly about exposing a narrative
yes and and the dementing thing is it's
in front of us all the time and
particularly I mean I want to say some
of this stuff and explain some of this
stuff and White House on this stuff
because I know how difficult it is for
instance for a young heterosexual male
to do any of it and I think it needs to
be done in a way on their behalf to make
it easier but you know we have this
thing at the moment where a young man is
assumed to be the one wielding power in
any relationship with a woman that the
woman has no power and that a set of
things happen which I think are
impossible
to do I mean one of the things I do
through this book is what are the
impossible demands that are being asked
of us and one of the impossible demands
perhaps one of the in some ways one the
least significant and there's some of
them that are total but one of them one
of the demands that's that's so
important is I should be able to be sexy
without being sexualized and that's
that's a really interesting modern
demand because actually we all know that
basically if you're being sexy you're in
the sex game somehow you're in you're
playing with a thing you know about the
other party knows about it doesn't mean
the other party can do whatever they
like obviously not but the stuff is in
the air now the current thing is that if
a woman puts that in the air the man is
barely allowed to respond unless the
woman gives the absolutely clear sign
and indeed explicit sign that that is
what is being asked for now I am I go
into this in the book via the perhaps
surprising route of Nicki Minaj and I'm
told by the way that people who bought
the audio book for this which I did
myself particularly pleased with my
recitation of the work but I I find this
fascinating because there's there's one
video in particular of hers called
anaconda which really shows this demand
that's being made she crawls on all
floors towards a very handsome young
black guy sitting in a in a chair she
does a kind of lap dance for him she
does everybody's more than the lap dance
it's not just a like a you know stripper
bar thing it's a it's a full-on
you know demonstration to him that she
is in the sex game our legs are around
his neck and she's twerking her
at him his face and all this stuff and
towards a very very end he's clear he
wants to touch her and then at the very
end he puts one hand on her hip she
turns whips around smacks him away and
walks off it's I I will play the sex
game as much as I like and you have no
right unless I ask you to to even put a
hand like that but that that's dementing
for the male I mean it is actually
saying to the male well summed up in the
words make him drool I have a I have an
interest in these memes that that we all
know about but which we pretend we don't
make him drool is a particularly
fascinating one because you can even see
this online there is no male equivalent
if you do if you type make him drool
into Google and this is so this is a
well-known sort of feat meme deranged
the man to make the man mad with desire
for you whether it's high heels or you
know famous examples of lipstick in all
sorts of things there are all sorts of
ways to do this but make him drool is a
recognized mean by the way if you talk
if you type make her drool gonna make
you're gonna iron your polo shirt to
kitty well what are you going to do
[Music]
comes up with how to stop yourself
drooling in bed when you're asleep
searches for cats that drool and I'm not
saying there's no way of obviously there
are ways for men to make women find them
more attractive but it's not quite the
meme of Dement the woman we're not the
same as the point right yeah but it is
not also I mean that there's a
counter-argument to this would be look
this is just a rear dressing of the
balanced men about it far too good for
too long they could get away with you
know grabbing a woman yes and nothing
would ever happen and now it's our turn
to bring a little bit of it so the
I do here it is it's an overcorrection
but we're doing overcorrection and this
goes on in the gay argument and it goes
on it goes on a little bit in the racial
argument as well are we after equality
or are we after better in each of these
cases it's a really dangerous one this I
would argue in each of these cases we
have wittingly or unwittingly gone to
better we think we're doing better for a
time to make up for lost time to
overcorrect but my question to that is
how do you know when the over
Corrections gone on long enough
and who announces time how long do for
instance young men have to be made to go
through the overcorrection game in order
to get back to the Equality bit and
we'll the overcorrection industry be
interested in saying all the time so
that's it whither does everybody who
benefited from the overcorrection
voluntarily go back to equal I mean
again we have these ones that we've
agreed I again I can maybe I can say
this but there's definitely a sense in
the society in which gay is a bit better
a bit better not in every way not in
every way but a bit better it's a bit
cooler a bit like Oh a bit different a
bit different other boring straight
people who don't have anything to save
themselves in their straight way
[ __ ] the sort of gays are a bit more
glamorous or interesting or talented or
fabulous that sort of thing
not just equal a little bit better in
some ways not in every weapon in this
world now we have that with the women
one are women exactly the same as men or
better you know we have we're running
several programs at once in our society
women are absolutely the same and a bit
better how not small sources christine
lagarde a head of the IMF repeatedly
said in the decade since the crash that
if Lehman Brothers had been lame insists
as it might not have happened why why
either women are have equal competence
to men in the financial system or
they're different or they're different
and better so which is it Christine
Lagarde head of the IMF keeps on pumping
out this idea they're better we wouldn't
have financial crashes if we had women
more prominent in finance it's very hard
to sustain all of these ideas in your
head at the same time and not go a bit
mad well that's the point isn't it
because that her argument is actually
one that I personally agree with which
is I think if we had more women in those
industries in the top positions right
because women are less they're more risk
averse right on average right and there
are other differences between men and
women on average you may well end up
with with a company behavior that is
different if you have men in those
positions but what that requires you to
accept of course is that men and women
are different are different again if we
got to that stage you then have to work
out do we want less risk in the banking
sector and if so is it the case that we
need to pump women in in order to do
that more what are the sectors where we
need the pattern this isn't a new motif
the idea of the pacifying female force
to stop the rampaging male but where
for instance the occasions when we might
need the rampaging mail you know there
must be times a lodge firefighters you
know police officers
right right and we have all of these
endless painful dementing campaigns to
get more women in the fire service and
you know persuade them that this is this
is the career for them and then we're
just horrified at the fact that the
stats don't seem to be going up in
enough order and and I just think it's
again it's it's it's a it's it's
something we know it's something we
can't talk about and so we've decided to
lie about but but one of the interesting
I'm gonna get on the cuttlefish if it
kills me because because I think is it
can ever the clever people the social
advantage people as well you might say
work out how to get through dementing
here as a bit faster and can do so and
then lambaste the people who didn't make
it you know didn't catch up in time
didn't alter their behavior and their
language fast enough and the most the
the clearest example of this I would say
is in the behavior of males towards
women in the sort of post me to era and
I when I was researching the madness of
crowds I had the great pleasure of
speaking through some of the themes of
it with a bewildering array of friends
in a bewildering array of different
disciplines well my favorite
conversations was with a friend of the
biologist who just one day was
describing to me
the behavior of the cuttlefish as a form
of the mimic octopus as well but the the
the cuttlefish have an extraordinary
interesting thing about them which is
that there was a type of cuttlefish
where because a male to female ratio is
bad advantages of females against the
male's the and because the females tend
to go around with their male cuttlefish
it's hard for
male cuttlefish who a single bachelor
cuttlefish they have a strategy and
their strategy is that because the
female cuttlefish is smaller than the
male cuttlefish the male cuttlefish in
search of a bit of action can pretend to
be to assume the form of a female and
they they become smaller and because the
woman is going around with her consort
male cuttlefish and like male cuttlefish
is alert for other cuttlefish
competition they pretend to be smaller
they go around the female the male
thinks that they're not a threat and by
being small and diminutive they get
through and then they have their wicked
way now the moment miss fen said this to
me I just said oh my god it's I know so
many men doing that mmm I know so many
men it's a creepy male feminist yeah
it's the creepy male feminist and by the
way I had a very specific example of a
colleague of mine a spectator Freddie
gray had covered the [ __ ] hat protests
the anti-trump protests the women's
March just immediately after the
inauguration in 2017 and he had told me
that among very instant thing that
happened that day and again none of this
is to say you know what people complain
about what Donald Trump wasn't you know
didn't have any legitimacy you know all
that he'd behaved like a perfect
gentleman you know I think we can
probably all agree that wasn't the case
but what was interesting to me was what
this colleague told me about something
that happened at the end of the day
because they're all these young men from
the sort of you know Ivy League young
men among others who are on that on the
women's March and there's a party
afterwards that this colleague friend
turns up at and all these men is saying
around I can't do the American accent
but I can do the British equivalent
which is like yeah are so totally like
onboard with this like yeah
and they're all doing this and like yeah
I totally totally support like and
that's when the women are around and
when the last woman leaves his
particular group to go off and get some
beer one of the other guys goes the
other oh my god dude I can't believe a
most [ __ ] there is in this room it's
funny isn't it like we have an example
right now we're recording this in the
moment of Justin Trudeau being being
chased and harassed and whatever for I
mean how much did he blackout video just
evenings he just sat at home you know
not on video just enjoying a bit of
blacking up I mean what are you actually
said he doesn't know how many times he's
done is I've been brining up all my life
see everyone's got a hobby haven't they
but but the thing with that is that I
put you know dressing up as a line into
me I don't see what's racist about that
I don't know I don't think I don't think
we need to actually destroy Justin
Trudeau for that reason but the
hypocrisy of it this woke chieftain of
of the universe being the guy who's
being doing the blackface yes to me is
an inevitable reality don't you find it
might be evidence of the existence of
God just this in karma I love it but
actually none of the three of us have
believers of course but perhaps we'll be
converted by the sarahfey would be
really confusing does work in mysterious
ways guys we wanted to tell you we're
very excited to say we've got a new
sponsor which is hellofresh indeed we
have hellofresh
is a UK's leading recipe box service
delivering fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and step-by-step recipes to
your door it is the easy convenient way
to cook delicious dinners from scratch
every single time choose your favorites
from 19 recipes every
week they have a whole range of options
there for you including recipes that are
ready in under 20 minutes there's family
favorites there's British cuisine
there's world cuisine there's even a 550
calories or under range and that's a
great thing because as you may have
noticed in the time that we've been
doing the show Frances has actually lost
quite a bit of weight so congratulations
to him on going from being massively fat
to just being really fat that's great
and if you want to achieve the same
results as Frances keep eating lard but
if you want to be healthy and slim like
me check out these extra healthy recipes
from hellofresh hellofresh we're
offering trigonometry fans sixty pounds
or four boxes to take advantage of that
go to hello fresh taco de UK enter our
special code which is of course
trigonometry and enjoyed delicious
dinners without any of the drama the
fresh ingredients come direct from
suppliers ie they've been picked by
Constantine's family
you can tell Frances studied geography
at a British school because he can't
tell the difference between Russia and
Romania doesn't matter mate
same thing breaks it means breaks it and
the great thing is it's been
proportioned for you so there's no food
waste
just like in my home country of
Venezuela the great thing we've had
fresh is that you're gonna be able to
choose from 19 different recipes every
week so there is something for everybody
you're gonna be able to eat with you
kids it's going to be no fuss dinnertime
it's gonna be solved yeah I really like
the rapid box which allows you to cook
things in under under 20 minutes but the
great thing about hellofresh as well is
it actually allows you to open up your
cooking range so most households on
average have about six recipes that they
cook regularly hellofresh has up to 19
so you can kind of expand a little bit
in terms of your cooking and of course
they also don't have a fixed
subscription so there's no term you can
cancel you can skip weeks you can change
the size of the box you can change the
livery address you can do all kinds of
stuff to suit your life to enjoy
delicious moments head over to
hellofresh code UK choose your box
choose your delivery slot and add your
favorite recipes discover the easy way
to get delicious dinners from scratch
and if you do that you'll get sick abs
just like me hello fresh we're offering
trigonometry fans 60 pounds off four
boxes
take advantage of that go to hello fresh
taco de UK enter our special code which
is of course trigonometry and enjoy
delicious dinners without any of the
drop is the backlash because it's going
to be a backlash and it could actually
be incredibly ugly yeah I think so
I think we I think I warned about this
because there's a say correcting the
over correction if that's what it is is
I think it is means you you could
probably the best way to do it is argue
and urge people to see what comes if
this goes on I think that's a case with
the with the male-female relations just
like we we should be able to have a more
reasonable discussion than we have we
should be able to remember things we all
knew we shouldn't end up in the sort of
themes of things like believe all women
you know we should we should try to get
a believe people if they appear to be
telling the truth something like that
will be you know a solid fashion yeah
yeah and and I think the one that's
that's in a way clearest that one I
worry about most in a way is the the
race one because again I mean this is
just a hellish subject but varies there
is something very dark starting to go on
with this and it comes I think you see
the start of it in what is called
whiteness studies whiteness studies is
the only such study in American Academy
which studies something not in order to
in some way celebrate it but in order to
destroy or denigrate it it's a very very
sinister movement it's been going on for
a few decades now and it comes out of
forms of other forms of studies but you
see gays studies came up because there
was a feeling I I actually oppose all
such studies I don't think any of them
have done that
good I think I've done quite a lot of
provable harm but gate study students
came up with idea that there were
authors who had not been focused upon
because they were gay they've been sort
of forgotten and that this could this
was a sort of forgotten this was
something that could deserves a like
being brought on and then it being
brought above the surface a bit more and
the same thing happened with with Black
Studies that there were authors and
others figures from history who've been
overlooked because of the color of their
skin and in an age of racism and in a
racist age had not been able to get the
the attention they deserve now there is
something in this undoubtedly but once
you once you get to a certain point
where like James Baldwin is just one of
the great writers of the 20th century
and you you wouldn't want him to be in a
Canon of black writers you'd want him
not even to be in a Canon of American
writers you just want to be him to be in
the Canon of 20th century writers and
you know again there are lots of gay
writers it's not being a not being a
paucity of them in history as it happens
but you don't want them to be in the
like the LGBTQ section everyone else I
said maybe there's a little bit of
correction that and it was needed there
in its day but all of these things were
designed to try to bring out something
that had otherwise potentially been
suppressed in some way and to celebrate
it all of them do that except for
whiteness studies and whiteness studies
is explicitly an attempt to problematize
being white this is really toxic stuff
and I show in in the chapter on race the
sort of consequences because if you
problematize any group of people if you
if you problematize any skin color it
means you are problematizing some people
the people who have that skin color and
you see this in the culture now the use
of the of the term white as a derogatory
term you see these ones with gammon and
things like that you know
hilarious Hilaire when racism is
hilarious
and I'm not I'm not saying you know
people say oh well you're probably just
saying this because you're a white gamma
knee so on say no I I'm noticing it
because it disturbs me and I don't like
the tone of it and what's more I can
start to see what's going to happen back
because just as surely as with any group
of people if you say your skin color is
a problem there will be some people who
will go along with that and there will
be a lot and I would suggest the
majority actually who say excuse me
excuse me
this is a hardware thing it has nothing
to do with my character or my life
choices it's neither good nor bad it is
amoral nothing just like I would submit
the position we should be in on issues
to do with sexual identity and issues to
do with being a man or being a woman it
is not a diet is not the way to look at
me and it doesn't say anything either
good or bad
but with the whiteness studies thing it
pushes this idea know being black is
better being anything is better than
being white and I just know already
what's going to happen with this you can
see little glimpses of it I give the
example of the Harvard case of the Asian
students so in Harvard University for
discriminating against them
but I I see it from the fact that in the
last I'd say three years in particular
everywhere in the world I go I'm in a
different country every week and have
been for the last few years I travel
very widely and I get to speak I'm very
fortunate if I get to speak to an
awfully large number of people one of
the things I have noticed is that
everywhere I go there are people
starting to ask questions about IQ and
it if it doesn't come up in QA and it
almost never does then it comes up
afterwards or somebody afterwards in a
pub or in a bar somebody will ask about
and I know what's happening when I say
this explicitly in the book I think this
is a sign of the sort of grabbing for
weapons ideological weapons to hit back
at the problematization of whiteness
there whatever we don't need to get into
it but whatever view you take on the
debate about IQ and hereditary
characteristics it's a really ugly ugly
thing and just a hellish hellish subject
and David Reich at Harvard and others
have explained very clearly why that is
but there are reasons why things come to
the surface and become a bit popular at
a particular time let alone sort of
everywhere what you know they say when I
started to notice it I thought why I'm
pretty sure I'm pretty sure this is
what's happening it is it is saying
right we're gonna find the weapon
nearest a hand that hurts you the most
in our view and we're gonna wield that
back so I say on this as on all of these
other subjects please let us step back
from leaning on them this March let's
let's try to go back to color blind
mm-hmm let's go back to race blind if we
can let's go back to not caring about
the characteristics if we can because
it's definitely preferable to what's
coming otherwise and can we go back is
there a way to solve this because this
is what I've been worrying about and you
know the fact that we all in these
tribes in an order to be black do you
have to be liberal and if you're not
what you know whybut idea mm-hmm is
there a way to go back I tried to
towards the end of the book I tried to
explain what I think are some of the
ways out and I'm particularly concerned
about this for what I said in the
beginning was that third group of people
young people growing up and it's very
confusing wild wanting to do good and
thinking this is good I'm very keen to
try to encourage them out of this way of
thinking and so I try to give some of
the examples of what you might do to try
to
out of it one of them one of them is to
do I have a chapter honest about
forgiveness and this is a really this
isn't great subject for comedy but it's
a great subject we we live in a very
very unforgiving society and you know
some people talk about things like
snowflake curry and someone of the
generation coming up and I I think that
it's slightly unfair unkind if you live
in a world where acting in the world can
come back at you at any stage and you
never ever have any mechanisms to be
forgiving you are going to fear
everything because everything is so damn
dangerous every word is undoable is
unendurable every action is undoable and
nobody wants to help you out nobody and
we all have a little bit of this you
know when somebody earns and strays or
does something terrible we are inclined
to forgive them if we already agree with
them if they are of our group or tribe
or if they are of our political view but
when it happens with our opponents we
destroy destroy and make sure they never
come back that's why the trudeau thing
is actually quite a useful moment
because I'm quite encouraged by some of
the response um of the partisan response
which is saying don't let's do this but
don't let's do back to him what we know
he would do to us so it's true that if
Donald Trump had repeatedly you know I
don't know how many times but sometimes
I just used to put my feet up at Trump
Tower and just black up Melania I don't
reckon we'd just be there on the
tambourine yeah
I reckon he'd have trouble in the
Republican primary
I reckon that the left wouldn't let go
of that and so it's it's interesting
because this could be an opportunity to
try to pretend the Justin Trudeau is in
fact a racist white supremacist KKK hood
wearing maniac and bigoted and a lot of
Canadian politicians are doing that some
are doing it yeah the wiser ones will
realize that this is a very important
opportunity to show magnanimity and
victory to say you couldn't wanted you
Justin Trudeau wanted to make us play
these silly reductive political games
and you know God knows as a reason
enough to dislike the guy he you know I
mean I still think that at that moment a
few years ago and when a young woman in
the audience were first to mankind and
he said he the Prime Minister of Canada
says I think you'll find we refer to to
humankind these days that's simply first
of all no we don't but almost nobody
does and secondly so you're the Prime
Minister and you're using the platform
to sort of correct from some brow beat
by that mansplain just asking a question
you know I mean no you have some decent
seats I'm just basic you know I mean
there's a power dynamic that's gone
wrong anyhow but it's such a point
whenever that guy gets this wrong by
turning out to have a bit of a thing for
doing blackface can't believe our luck
you know we could do the dishonest thing
to him that he would do all we could say
okay let's use this as an opportunity to
learn about how we could have a better
better thing going forward and I I give
this example with V with V in the
forgiveness chapter with E how do we how
do we how do we try to read other
people's words including the words of
people who we might disagree with in a
more honest light we've had this thing I
may have said to you before we've had
this strange thing in our society in
recent years writers comedians and
others used to operate on the basis that
we spoke and acted in a way that no
honest critic could honestly
misrepresent and then we entered at some
point in recent years is era in which we
had to try to speak and act in a way in
which you know in such a way that no
dishonest person couldn't dishonestly
misrepresent our actions and that can't
be done
Holy's it can't be done without driving
yourself mad and so we need to we need
to work out how with our opponents as
well as our allies and friends and and
so on actually behave in a more
reasonable manner and I by the way just
a quick example I had a I had an example
of this the other day somebody told me
that that it was a social some social
thing it's quite a very wide array of
people of different backgrounds all that
sort of thing
and somebody said to me who happened to
be a I haven't not to be white
themselves said that somebody that the
same thing had referred to that you know
you know the colored girl and this this
this friend mentioned this to me and was
clearly just sort of like do you think
he was being a bit you know do you think
he's a bit racist and I didn't know the
person well but I said for my little
interaction with her I said I know I
wouldn't I don't think so and and I sort
of we sort of talked about it a bit
because it was interesting that I said
to her well I reckon he's just of that
generation where you still said colored
people not people of color which i think
is a distinction without much of a
difference
you know fine you know he probably
didn't get that memo and why don't we
assume he just misspoke and doesn't know
the latest thing but doesn't hate black
people
why don't we assume that rather than oh
my god there was a racist incident at
that party I just think that's probably
for all of us and more no that doesn't
mean you don't call that bigotry when
you actually find it but we should we
should probably try to find a more
reasonable way along those lines well
some of so much of it is about intent I
had an incident very much like that and
my comedy club which I run after show
which I booked and all the gentlemen
came up to me and he said oh I loved the
first act that you had on you know the
colored chap and and and I thought about
it yeah in this modern way and then I
went well hold on what is his intention
there yeah his intention is quite
clearly to implement this person and
their perform right they just haven't
been updated on the language yeah and
this is what I don't understand is when
did racism stop being about what you
said which is hating black people and
became this failure to comply with the
linguistic code issued two weeks ago by
the commissariat you know what I mean
yeah I think well obviously
the most common explanation is it's
being done by people who want to win on
something else and it's very much the
left of the vanguard of this so I I'm on
the left and you know a trade union
member former teacher all the rest of it
and I've just been driven to despair by
their behavior where the worse side and
a lot of the time yeah it's it's it's a
horrible it's a horrible thing to see
this and as I say we need to like lean
back from what we're trying to lean into
at the moment I I mean here's a tricky
one to say but why didn't I do it anyway
um you know I I grew up in London in the
80s and London was already very diverse
and I maybe you know whenever the best
analysts of our own actions but when I
look back I can say with absolute
honesty
I didn't think skin color was of any
significance hmm
in fact I remember my parents telling
that when my grandparents was rather
struck once by mentioning that you know
as a primary school or something and
when I was and I had mentioned a friend
to this grandparent and he said which
which which friend is that and I took to
drive described that when I was
describing this guy I didn't at any
point say she's black and he was just
very struck by that but it was like oh
you know I was like you know the girl
with with black hair that you know in
the glasses but it didn't that wasn't
sorry if you grow up like that you don't
think it's you know is have any
importance or that interesting so I I
sort of particularly resent the re
racialization of society because I think
it is making everybody notice things and
let me give you an example um you know
Martin Amos once said that he his father
Kingsley was a little bit anti-semitic
and Martin Amos once said that he said
to his father who was a self-confessed
slightly anti-semitic person what's it
like being mildly anti-semitic and
Kingsley Amos said to his son well you
know it's nothing it's nothing very
serious but he said just things like you
know he said I'd watch the television
and you know when the credits roll you
know I look at all the names I go
there's one
I mean now we know where Jeremy I mean
you actually you have to know if you
grow up around a lot of people and none
of them are Jewish you wouldn't know if
you go up with a lot of people and some
of them were Jews it's likely he just
wouldn't notice that okay I remember
again I mean it took I was quite over I
knew what an particular name would be
that would probably denote that the
person was Jewish you know I mean
because it wasn't a thing
now the reason I mentioned this is
because increasingly in recent years the
way in which race has been weaponized I
noticed that everybody is becoming a
little bit like that thing that Kingsley
Amos was trying to describe so people
now take the advertising thing all
adverts have mixed race couples and the
children are black or mixed-race and
it's a very common meme in advertising
in fact if you have an advert where
there's no one
everybody's white like that company is
gonna be in serious trouble and then the
thing is it makes perfect sense in one
way because first of all you're trying
to reflect an increasingly diverse
society and secondly you you know you
want to sort of show people like this
isn't it's normal to have you know
mixed-race marriages which it is and so
on but there's something sometimes about
it where you can't just lay off it a bit
you know where you can predict exactly
what they're going to do in terms of the
racial quota for the advert and I just
noticed that everyone ends up noticing
race yeah and it's because it's
something we didn't notice
strangely enough by trying to correct it
in this way we all notice it and I just
be for myself I think it's horrible yeah
yeah I just think it's horrible do you
use a very interesting example in your
book with the Google searches Google
that's terrifying people can do it
themselves at home although maybe if
enough attention is paid to it Google
will change the algorithm I mean I
discovered what I spent some time in
Silicon Valley was researching this book
and you know I got very interested in a
single machine learning fairness which
is MOF is how you assuming because human
beings I do have some instinctive
prejudices and biases and so on and if
you're programming you don't want to put
your biases into the program so if it is
the case that most physicists
historically have been men you don't
want all physicists to come up on the
search to be men because that might
suggest to a young woman who what might
want to be a physicist if she searches
that she
because they're all male in the physics
business so the good bit of this problem
is you don't want to put off people with
a competency and an ambition from doing
whatever they want the problem is that
the MLF thing comes up with some very
weird things with history it produces
for instance surveys of the past that
are just not reflective of the past
which suggests for instance that Europe
was basically a highly multicultural
society throughout you know the last
millennium it's just not the case I mean
you might people might wish it's the
case or not wish it's the case but it
just it just wasn't the case but there
is something which I identify which is
machine learning fairness plus some
human agency and it clearly happens with
google image searches so that and as
they try this at home
search for gay couples on Google Image
Search and you get lots of happy healthy
gay couples some of them a men male
couple some of female couples and
there's an awful lot of adoption and you
know children as well just to show happy
gay families but they're basically no
sort of nice cute sexy sweet couples do
straight couples and you get gay couples
a lot a lot this gets darker do black
couples or black families and you get
lots of nice photos of nice happy
healthy black couples and black families
do white couples or white family you
don't get it you get a lot of black
couples interracial couples you get a
lot of gay couples you want your if you
don't white couple you will get a black
gay couple why Silicon Valley has
decided that only a bigot would be
searching for white couples or straight
couples and they're saying [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you will show you will show you will
taunt you will DeMint you we know what
you're about bigot now the thing about
this is
like we didn't we don't know this is
happening mainly and it's only a sped-up
version of something that is happening
elsewhere in the media and politics I
lay that out the slow version of it is
happening elsewhere the fastest version
is the online one but this again this is
dementing and this is very very bad for
a society to unwittingly be imbibing a
very distorted picture which selects
groups of people who do not deserve to
have the thing they might be searching
for but deserve instead to be punished
and demented and told they can't access
it and again Asian couples you'll get
happy Asian couples the Asians deserve
to see happy Asian couples but that's
not the case with everyone why because
we know in Silicon Valley there are some
people who are bigoted and we know who
they are and we're going to get them
well it's almost like the tech companies
have an agenda front yeah we wouldn't
know anything about that obviously on
the show it's highly demonic for this
show you have to pay their money you'll
get money taken from your bank accounts
and given to YouTube in order to allow
you this with you is such a pleasure we
would be prepared to pay in truth and
I'm giving it to unvarnished thank you
so much for coming on the last question
we always ask is what is the one thing
that we're not talking about that we
should be talking about and I know it's
weird to ask you given you've just
written the whole book about things that
we should be talking about but give us
something last time you said it was your
book so we've talked about you know I I
think the thing we should be thinking
about is that that when I I raised
earlier which I've tried in recent days
to put out there a bit and with with a
lack of success with some of my
opponents in this discussion but I
really urge them and everyone else to
think about it what would what would
overcorrection
look like and when would you know and
who would call it and how could we get
back to equal how could we escape better
and get back to equal on all of the
rights issues it's got to be possible
and we've got to think about it and so
we should work out what the warning
signs would be that we've overreached
and work the way work out the way back
to basically having the equalities that
most of us want and then get on with
doing better and more interesting things
with our lives and more meaningful
things because it's just not going to be
good for this generation to be playing
these games of privilege there is so
much for them to do and so much good
that can be done and I think we should
be getting on with that
that's a very good message to leave the
interview on thank you so much for
coming on make sure you get the madness
of crowds it's an absolutely brilliant
book we both really enjoyed it we will
see you very soon
we've got some very exciting news I'm
only Constantine yes we do I will be
doing my extremely well reviewed and
popularly enjoyed show called all well
that ends well which I did at the
Edinburgh Fringe here in London at the
Bill Murray comedy club which is an
angel in his Lincoln on the 16th of
November which is a Saturday at 5:30 and
I thought I'd try and create a contrast
between good comedy and bad comedy so
I've invited Francis to emcee as well
absolutely now because he's invited me
we've sold some tickets for the show we
are also gonna need more of you to come
and support comedy and in support comedy
no there will support me I am comedy and
support Constantine as he delivers his
lecture - no I'm joking
- come and watch a show it's going to be
brilliant it's going to feature me at
the top doing a little bit of ten
minutes of banter calling people fat
pricks and then we're going to bring
Constantine on yeah we like hypocrisy so
it's gonna be absolutely awesome it's
going to be in London it's gonna be at
the Bill Murray pub at 5:30 p.m. on
Saturday the 16th of November we'll see
you there
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media at trigger part
and also leave us a nice review on
iTunes and spread the word
[Music]